>> WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW.
IN CHICAGO THE PUBLIC IS
OUTRAGED OVER THE DECISION TO
BLOCK ACCESS TO POLICE SCANNERS.
THE SHIFT TOWARDS THE USE OF AN
ENCRYPTED RADIO FREQUENCY IS
ABOUT POLICE SAFETY.
SOME SAY IT IS CENSORSHIP.
CRIME IS ABOUT TO GET WORSE.
ILLINOIS BECOMES A FIRST STATE
TO GET RID OF CASH BAIL IN 2023.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL
EDITORIAL BILL CRITICIZED THE
POLICY WRITING DEMOCRATS HAVE
FULL CONTROL OF STATE GOVERNMENT
IN ILLINOIS.
SO THEY CAN TAKE FULL CREDIT ON
THE MESS UNFOLDING AT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
MAY ASSUME WITH REELECTION
BEHIND HIM BUT HE CAN GET AWAY
WITH USING CITIZENS AS HUMAN
EXPERIMENTS IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
VOTERS WHO SEE RISING MAYHEM IN
THE STREETS WILL KNOW WHOM TO
BLAME.
RAIMENT, COMING TO YOU FIRST.
TRYING TO EXPLAIN THIS AWAY AS
POLICE SAFETY.
THIS IS ABOUT, FOR THE PRESS,
THEIR ABILITY TO SEE WHAT IS
GOING ON.
CRIME HAS RISEN 41% IN THE CITY
OF CHICAGO.
NOW, ILLINOIS WANTS TO GET RID
OF BAIL ALTOGETHER.
>> JUST AS THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY, NEW JERSEY IS TRYING TO
WALK BACK IT'S NO CASH BAIL.
WHY?
THEY ARE OVERWHELMED WITH CRIME.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
NO PROSECUTIONS FOR CERTAIN
CRIMES.
WE RELEASE PEOPLE, REPEAT
OFFENDERS INTO THE STREET.
BLOODSHED EVERYWHERE.
WHERE THE MURDER CAPITAL OF THE
COUNTRY THIS YEAR.
NEW ORLEANS.
TRAGIC.
CHICAGO.
PEOPLE SHOT AND NOW YOU ARE
SAYING WE WILL NOT LET THE
PUBLIC OR JOURNALISTS LISTEN TO
A POLICE SCANNER TO KNOW WHERE
THE CRIME IS?
I'M SORRY, WE DO NOT HAVE ONE
CASE WHERE A JOURNALIST SOMEHOW
COMPROMISED A CRIME SCENE OR IN
ANY WAY ENDANGERED THE PUBLIC.
YOU KNOW WHAT ENDANGERS THE
PUBLIC LOUSY PROSECUTION.
HAVING YOUR POLICE WALK AWAY AND
NO RECRUITMENT AND CASHLESS
BAIL.
WE ARE DOING THE OPPOSITE HERE
AND WE ARE SUPPRESSING PUBLIC
INFORMATION.
WHY?
WHY IS THIS AN IMPULSE.
>> THE MAYOR HAS AN EXPLANATION.
LET'S LISTEN AND HEAR.
>> IT IS ABOUT OFFICER SAFETY.
IF IT IS UNENCRYPTED AND THERE
IS ACCESS, THERE IS NO WAY TO
CONTROL CRIMINALS WHO ARE GOING
TO ALSO GET ACCESS LISTEN IN AND
ADJUST THEIR CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
AND RESPONSE TO THE INFORMATION
THAT IS BEING COMMUNICATED.
>> LISA, IS IT ABOUT OFFICER
SAFETY?
>> NO.
I THINK SHE IS EVIL.
I REALLY TRULY MEAN THAT.
YOU HAVE A WAR ZONE IN HER CITY
AND SHE DOESN'T CARE SHE IS
DOING TIKTOK VIDEOS.
I TRULY THINK THAT SHE IS EVIL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ANY HUMAN BEING
CAN SEE SUCH SUFFERING AND SUCH
LOSS IN THEIR CITY AND NOT SEE
IT IN CARE.
IT TRULY IS DISGUSTING.
GETTING RID OF CASH BAIL WILL
LEAD TO INCREASED CRIME.
WE SOUGHT IN NEW YORK CITY AFTER
THERE WAS BAIL REFORM.
CRIME HAD ALREADY RISEN BY 20%
ALONE SINCE THE YEAR BEFORE.
DO NOT EVER VISIT ILLINOIS.
WE ARE TALKING CRAZY CRIMES, TWO
OH.
IT WILL FREE THOSE IN CUSTODY
FOR AGGRAVATED MURDER,
AGGRAVATED BATTERY, DRUG-INDUCED
HOMICIDE, KIDNAPPING, REAL
THINGS.
WE ARE ALREADY SAYING THAT IT IS
JUST A REVOLVING DOOR OF CRIME.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE CASH BAIL, I
HAVE ONE WAY TO AVOID IT, DON'T
COMMIT CRIMES, IDIOTS.
>> WHAT THE COALITION IS SAYING
ABOUT THIS.
THE MAYOR'S DECISION TO RESTRICT
OUR ACCESS WILL HARM OUR ABILITY
TO KEEP YOU, OUR READERS,
VIEWERS, LISTENERS SAFE AND
INFORMED.
RENDER IT MORE DIFFICULT TO HOLD
OUR GOVERNMENT AND ITS PERSONNEL
ACCOUNTABLE.
SHE KNOWS THAT CRIME IS GOTTEN
WORSE AND IT IS ABOUT TO GET
EVEN WORSE.
>> AND YOU WONDER WHY YOU DO NOT
WANT THE PRESS TO KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
HERE IS THAT THING.
IT JUST BAFFLES MY MIND.
THIS IS WHY THE MEDIA IN CHICAGO
ARE SO LIVID.
IF IT'S ABOUT OFFICER SAFETY,
FINE.
SOME PLACES DO PREVENT THE
PUBLIC FROM HAVING ACCESS TO
SCANNER TRAFFIC.
BUT TO NOT LET THE MEDIA HAVE
ACCESS, THIS IS LITERALLY HOW WE
LEARN ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
COMMUNITY.
IT IS THE LIFEBLOOD.
HOW WE GET STORY TIPS AND HOW WE
KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
IT IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED IN TEXAS.
FOR HOW LONG DID THE POLICE
THERE CONTINUE TO PAINT A
PICTURE, AND NARRATIVE OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
HOW DID WE FIND OUT WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS.
SCANNER TRAFFIC.
IT HAPPENS OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
IF WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT.
ESPECIALLY IN A PLACE LIKE
CHICAGO.
POLICE OFFICERS, LORI LIGHTFOOT,
PUBLIC SERVANTS, YOU ARE
PREVENTING THEM FROM DOING THEIR
JOB.
>> THAT KIND OF REPORTAGE SAVES
LIVES.
A CITY LIKE NEW ORLEANS, A CITY
LIKE CHICAGO, YOU TURN THE CAR
AROUND AND GO THE OTHER WAY TO
STAY AWAY FROM THAT AREA.
LORI LIGHTFOOT WANTS TO LOCK UP
INFORMATION.
SHE SHOULD BE LOCKING UP
CRIMINALS.
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
>> WHEN DID WE BECOME SO DISSENT
ADVISED IN THE LOSS OF LIFE IN
AMERICA.
WE TALK ABOUT THESE NUMBERS ALL
THE TIME.
YOU READ THOSE NUMBERS, THEY ARE
AWFUL.
WE JUST CANNOT WRAP OUR HANDS
AROUND I